reaction is the acting deputy secretary
of the department of homeland security
ken cuccinelli um
was this like an invitation you know the
idea that they're going to have
well it's apparently biden's team is
saying in the first uh
10 days that's a top priority amnesty
yeah yeah of course it is and um you
know
it was this isn't a surprise or a shock
to anyone
and while i don't like it or appreciate
it or think it's consistent with the law
it's not like joe biden snuck up on
anybody with this right i mean this is
what he said he was going to do
and while and what we were saying all
along in the department of homeland
security was
hey look you're going to get way more
than you bargained for
and we we saw the trump effect you know
this amazing drop
voluntary drop in illegal immigration
when president trump was sworn in
because of the expectations he created
and now we're seeing the biden effect
because of the expectations
that he has created but your reporter
sarah made a
really critical point and that is the
covid in there
so when these caravans come up
and really the whole illegal immigrant
pipeline sean
they're in tight conditions that they
don't control
with people who don't care about them
let's be very clear about that
and it is an absolute human petri dish
opportunity
for the transmission of a demonstrably
very transmissible virus and of course
we have to worry about this new strain
now
ken i'll use biden's word that looks
like a super spreader event
it really does and you know is it sure
for americans
if they're going to have a mask mandate
and you know government imposed
shutdowns in states in the country
uh is it too much to ask that we'd be
able to check the people come legally
check out any radical background
associates they may have or associations
you know check in the age of covert make
sure they're not
you know they don't have covert they
can't transmit covert
into some people
well and sean you know uh the
guatemalans have fought this really hard
i mean with
yeoman's effort really for a nation of
their resources
and that's a result of the
accomplishments of this administration i
mean
a big part of the way we fought illegal
immigration
was with partnerships with el salvador
honduras guatemala
mexico and they've done more this is the
first caravan that's gone anywhere
since early 2019 because of the
uh relationships that president trump
achieved and let's face it he
he it was hard-nosed negotiating if
you'll remember almost two years ago and
the president was criticized
substantially on both sides of the aisle
for being so tough
but it worked we have the most fruitful
relationships in this area
with mexico and the northern triangle
countries ever
and i hope the new administration will
not flush
all that very productive effort down the
drain
all right ken cuccinelli thank you